a lot of sports teams out there are  asking their fans not to do the wave  anymore during the game have you heard  that yeah  not me the joke I'm mad at the premise  yes no people don't want them sports  teams are saying please don't do the  wave they say it's distracting and even  disrespectful to the players and I've  noticed this it's not just sports teams  that are suffering from this problem  lately  check out my recent interview with Will  Arnett there's a lot of excitement out  there about the new Arrested Development  show so you're gonna make more aren't  you yeah we're planning on we're  planning on making more episodes we're  really excited about it I'm looking for  big Fivefinger paid  [Applause]  I think that  [Applause]  you know there's an appetite cord and I  think that people want to see it though  I'll relate  sit here while your crowd does the  goddamn wave  you